[Musique]
il y a quelques mois scandale sanitaires
de grande ampleur à toucher l'Hexagone
si vous avez dans votre congélateur des
produits de la marque fraîcheur de
vuittoni il vous est demandé de les
jeter sans délai hier soir France 2
proposer un nouveau numéro d'envoyer
spécial consacré à l'affaire budony en
dévoilant des informations et des
témoignages inédits il a commencé à
avoir des convulsions et il a été
hospitalisé en réanimation de nouvelles
informations qui ont une série les
téléspectateurs et qui n'ont pas hésité
à partager leurs colères sur les réseaux
sociaux comment cette marque peut-elle
encore exister témoignage de salariés
détresse de famille lourde révélation
dans Envoyé Spécial sur l'affaire des
pizzas Buitoni
[Musique]
merci Julien d'être avec nous merci
Julien qui vient souvent nous voir
consultant communication de crise
directeur de la French com et on
embrasse également florianiki voilà que
je la kiffe un gros bisou et Roger Rua
un médecin merci beaucoup d'être là
bonteur parce que c'est vrai que on a
envie de savoir comment ça se passe et
ce qui se passe alors le reportage a
commencé par un Kaboul version qui a ému
énormément de téléspectateurs donc
Géraldine qui a regardé
ce jeune homme de cet enfant de 2 ans et
demi mort en mars dernier après avoir
mangé un bout de pizza surgelé Buitoni
de la gamme fraîche up on en avait parlé
ici et pour la première fois les parents
ont décidé de s'exprimer face aux
caméras regardez il a commencé à avoir
des des convulsions je suis retourné aux
urgences et c'est là que le diagnostic
du
SHU a été posé
et il a été hospitalisé en réanimation
[Musique]
le syndrome hémolytique et urémique
maladie grave qui se développe à la
suite d'une infection à la bactérie et
chéry-chiacoli
elle touche en particulier les enfants
et provoque la défaillance des organes
vitaux
[Musique]
et c'est vrai que ça tout le monde en a
parlé parce que c'était un incroyable
juste docteur comment il faut comment on
peut savoir qu'on a été intoxiqué aussi
gravement et quels sont les moyens de
réagir au plus vite alors d'abord on le
sait pas tout de suite parce que c'est
d'abord une intoxication alimentaire de
type banal c'est à dire qu'on peut avoir
des nausées quelques vomissements
malheur mal au ventre diarrhée et c'est
ensuite que malheureusement les choses
se gâtent parce que la bactérie peut
sécréter une toxine et c'est cette
toxine qui dans le sang va créer le
syndrome que dont on a parlé et qui va
entraîner lui le passage éventuellement
à l'hôpital ou en rénovation voir le
décès hier il y avait un envoyé spécial
sur Bitoni sur l'affaire Bitoni et
regarder ce qu'il dit est à peine
croyable
[Musique]
des scientifiques estiment qu'un gramme
de matière fécales peut contenir jusqu'à
1 milliard des chéries chiacoli
[Musique]
seulement 500 suffirait à rendre malade
un enfant
alors c'est vrai que oui
ou des intérimaires qui faisaient des
photos qui ont envoyé à la direction des
vidéos comme ça en disant faites gaffe
quand même ça va pas c'est pas propre
faites attention et la direction à
chaque fois non mais ça va c'est pas
grave ça va passer il y a pas d'alerte
et tout ça et donc en fait il y a une
sorte de déni mais qui est juste
scandaleux il y a eu quand même deux
morts et plus de 52 personnes qui ont
des séquelles à vie et donc c'est quand
même incroyable et tout ça pour la
rentabilité pour en faire plus pour
moins payer il y avait une entreprise
vous savez de pour nettoyer qui était
externe on va voir on va en parler dans
un instant juste Julien offrait
consultant communication comment on fait
dans cinq dans ces cas-là quand on est
une marque comme bettonie qui fait
partie du groupe Nestlé on fait quoi
dans la reportage comme ça c'est dans le
cas d'une crise mais malheureusement
c'est pas que ce reportage ça fait
depuis le mois de mars que ça dure la
difficulté de bétonie qui appartient
donc au groupe Nestlé c'est que ils sont
dans la négation la plus absolue depuis
le début ils ont peu à peu ensuite
douter ensuite ils ont appliqué le
silence total la difficulté c'est qu'ils
ont fait toutes les erreurs de
communication de crise tout ils les ont
toutes faites comme Lactalis il y a
plusieurs années là ce qui leur a fallu
faire c'est être évidemment mais ça
paraît presque évident il aurait fallu
être empathique avec les victimes
évidemment les contacter et pas
seulement leur envoyer un bon d'achat de
20 euros quand vous perdez votre enfant
et que vous recevez un bon d'achat de 20
euros
un appel Cyril pas un appel il y a juste
une vidéo zoom de du patron c'est tout
rien c'est ce qu'on appelle alors
Roger médecin pourquoi les enfants sont
plus touchés
alors pour la bonne et simple raison que
les enfants système immunitaires qui est
pas encore très développé et donc qui va
être sensible à cette toxine et donc à
la fois préciser aussi que
lui peuple notre intestin de façon très
très ample et qui a très faible
pourcentage de série chiens coliques qui
va provoquer cette toxine donc il faut
quand même pas penser que tout peut
s'affoler bien sûr ce généraliser mais
lorsque cette toxine et sécrétée par la
bactérie on a plus d'action sur la
bactérie parce que sur une bactérie un
peu encore avoir des antibiotiques qui
peuvent marcher et c'est la toxine qui
va réaliser le syndrome qui va ensuite
amener la réanimation
indispensable on a notre témoignage dans
le même sens que celui d'avant c'est un
autre salarié qui raconte que la
productivité était privilégiée à
l'hygiène c'est ce que nous disait
Géraldine un instant
non seulement le temps de nettoyage
aurait été réduit mais il est désormais
à la charge des employés alors que
jusque là une entreprise extérieure s'en
occupait
d'où vient cette décision
de nettoyage
extérieur
[Musique]
alors sachez que depuis le scandale
Bitoni les ventes de pizza surgelées ont
chuté de 34% toute marque confondues
c'est ça qui est fou c'est que en fait
ça touche toutes les autres marques
également et même les pizzas fraîches
qui n'ont pas été concernées par le
scandale on refroidit les français
puisque moins 9,4 %, voyez pas donc
c'est vrai que c'est tout tout le monde
de la pizza surgelée qui a qui a
souffert de ce scandale et vous allez
voir dans un instant un document
confidentiel révélé hier soir oui non
mais la question qu'on se pose c'est une
marque comme butoni peut se remettre à
moyen terme et à long terme à ce qu'on
appelle comme ça oui s'ils sont voué à
fermer tout simplement la difficulté de
de la difficulté précisément de Bitoni
c'est que comme ils ont passé huit mois
à nous expliquer que au fond c'était pas
de leur faute et qu'ils ont attendu
presque six mois pour écrire vos
familles on voit en fait qu'il y a une
sorte désolé du terme mais de foutage de
gueule généralisé vis-à-vis des feuilles
des familles se relever de ça c'est très
compliqué c'est possible mais les images
que l'on va voir ensuite montrent
clairement que malgré la crise de mars
la journaliste qui est en caméra cachée
un mois à moi un mois et demi
visiblement il y a aucun impact il y a
aucune réaction en interne alors cette
journaliste s'est fait embaucher comme
intérimaire dans la chaîne de production
des desserts de vous allez voir en fait
la c'est dans une usine de Nestlé et
Lactalis près de Nantes regardez les
règles sanitaires de base semblent être
oubliées par certains employés mais tu
peux absolument pas bravo
nous la suivons jusqu'à son poste elle
ne se lavera jamais les mains plus
visible encore l'état des blouses nous
en avons reçu deux à notre arrivée avec
pour seul indication de les laver
nous-mêmes
personne ne semble se soucier de leur
propre thé
cela fait trois semaines que je porte la
même blouse tous les jours trace de
graisse de yaourt de poussière aucun
chef est responsable qualité n'est venu
me voir pour me demander de remplacer ma
blouse et apparemment nous ne sommes pas
les seuls
révélé le problème qu'on a et la
question qui se pose et j'appose à
Julien c'est vrai que parfois on se dit
derrière qui va trinquer si Buitoni
ferme sont tous les employés ils ont ils
Nestlé on le sait que c'est ils
emploient des milliers d'employés et
voilà donc vous rendez compte derrière
vous allez avoir 300000 personnes qui
vont se retrouver sans emploi donc c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué c'est difficile
évidemment parce que ce sont des grands
notamment pour Nestlé c'est un grand
groupe international
quand vous travaillez pour une marque
comme cela vous n'avez pas
nécessairement non plus envie de vous
retrouver enfin de voir votre marque
pour qui vous travaillez de que vos amis
votre famille voit qu'en fait vous êtes
entre guillemets co-responsable de ce
qui est en train de se passer parce que
si vous travaillez pour buttoni
évidemment
l'image que que les gens ont de vous et
forcément négative Bitoni là il met
évidemment au-delà du fait que il met
dans la détresse la plus absolue un
certain nombre de familles avec des
morts et des victimes il met évidemment
un nombre incalculable de collaborateurs
l'image qui est collée à ses
collaborateurs est une image négative et
cette image négative malheureusement un
peu comme Lactalis il y a quelques
années elle va leur coller à la peau
alors oui ce qui est fou sur le
reportage que vous venez de passer en
caméra cachée c'est que c'est pas la
même usine que Caudry ou sommet les
témoignages les saletés sur Caudry c'est
une autre usine où elle allait aller
donc ça veut dire que effectivement ils
n'ont tenu de rien que ça continue alors
ils sont attaqués c'est à dire qu'on
leur réclame 255 millions d'euros mais
ce qui sont en train de faire Nestlé pas
buttoni Nestlé c'est qu'ils vont mettre
de côté une somme pas du tout celle-là
et puis ils vont espérer que ça passe
comme ça ils sont en train de tenter de
gagner du temps pour tenter de joindre
le groupe Nestlé pour les faire réagir à
l'hygiène aux bactéries regardez
s'agissant des autotests et des
écouvillonnages nous contestons
formellement les allégations dont vous
vous faites l'écho au contraire ils sont
basés sur une analyse des risques qui
permet d'évaluer les zones identifiées
comme les plus sensibles afin
d'effectuer ses prélèvements là où ils
sont nécessaires en référence aux pizzas
contaminées de l'usine de Caudry il va
même plus loin nous n'avons pas détecté
la bactérie echoolytech en 2021
voilà et vous savez pourquoi ils n'ont
pas détecté parce qu'en fait quand ils
font des tests ils appellent avant ils
préviennent en disant on va venir demain
ils ont 24 heures pour tout nettoyer et
comme ça effectivement ben personne
s'aperçoit qu'à un problème mais il y a
quand même un document interne qui dit
qu'à un moment ils ont détecté ça dans
la farine et justement là où c'est très
grave c'est que c'est à travers la
farine que l'on suppose que la
contamination a eu lieu
un document interne confidentiel en date
du 12 septembre dernier affirme le
contraire on y apprend qu'en août 2021
des traces dicholytech auraient été
détectées dans de la farine
[Musique]
voilà donc c'est ce document
confidentiels qui a été
révélée aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
docteur vous nous avez plutôt rassuré
mais est-ce que les Français qui nous
regardent peuvent aller acheter les
pizzas voilà surgelés comme ils le
faisait avant parce que c'est vrai que
aussi il y a une question de coût on le
sait voilà moi je sais que voilà moi je
consomme des pizzas autre chose moi
j'adore mon épilation jolie et c'est
vrai que là j'ai arrêté d'en acheter
voilà et c'est vrai que c'est c'est
simple c'est pratique mais aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on peut continuer en acheter
ou est-ce que on va y aller la peur au
ventre on se dit à chaque fois qu'on
mange une pizza on prend un risque
énorme
alors d'abord si toutes les conditions
d'hygiène sont respectées si toutes les
normes qui sont nombreuses en France se
respecter évidemment qu'on peut
continuer à consommer des pizzas
surgelées mais ce comment avoir le
certitude parce que là on ne voit pas
savoir si la pizza que vous consommez
était contrôlé ou pas donc c'est pas
possible d'autant plus qu'il y a pas de
signe de stigmate visuel de
l'infestation parce que c'est
microscopique bien entendu la seule
chose qu'on puisse faire c'est
réchauffer et recuire la pizza parce que
on sait que la chaleur détruit ces
bactéries ça mais enfin c'est pas très
bon une pizza surgelée que vous reculez
alors il faut aussi élargir de ce
problème d'hygiène à l'ensemble parce
qu'on parle que de la pizza surgelés qui
sont des bombes à retardement en fait
mais il y a aussi les pizzas fraîches si
les conditions d'hygiène sont pas
requises fixes requises ne sont pas
effectuées
au moment de la fabrication de nos
pizzas vous savez celle qu'on appelle
par téléphone et bien vous aurez le même
risque il faut pas affoler la population
mais il faut quand même recentrer le
problème sur l'hygiène on en avait
beaucoup parlé avec la crise de la
pandémie l'avez-vous les mains
l'avez-vous les mains les contrôles
aussi Julien
aujourd'hui c'est quoi les solutions
pour
les solutions pour le groupe on est
c'est quoi c'est déjà ça serait
évidemment d'arrêter de nier
systématiquement toutes les accusations
notamment quand il y a évidemment des
profs filmés ça paraît assez effarant
lui donner aujourd'hui doit être comme
toutes les entreprises mondiales et
françaises doivent mériter la confiance
des consommateurs et aujourd'hui on n'y
est pas du tout quoi la difficulté c'est
que cette crise elle a démarré il y a
plus de six mois et il continue
évidemment de négliger les normes
d'hygiène dans leurs usines comme la
tribundi Gilles on est sur une autre
usine donc ça montre très bien que ça
peut se passer dans toutes les usines
françaises depuis Tony et
potentiellement dans toutes les autres
usines Nestlé puisque l'une des l'une
des usines qu'on a vu c'est Nestlé
lactalisations
voudrait c'est des contrôles inopinés
dans les grandes entreprises comme ça
qu'on entre leurs mains des tonnes et
des tonnes de pizza qui vont nous donner
à nous qui vont nous nourrir on aimerait
des contrôler une opinions avec des
grosses amendes et on a l'impression que
c'est un peu magouillé on a l'impression
que les groupes payent un peu les
contrôles on vient dans deux jours
nettoyer tout j'en veux pas de ça on
veut pas on a l'impression c'est pas
normal qu'un groupe comme Nestlé laisse
passer ça c'est pas normal qu'un groupe
aussi fort que Nestlé avec on l'a dit
270 000 salariés des chiffres d'affaires
de 80 milliards si je me trompe pas se
fasse salir comme ça par un truc de
bruit Tony ou autre c'est c'est pas
normal et tu voulais rajouter quelque
chose qui est assez effarant qui est que
lorsqu'ils ont découvert dans le dans le
lorsqu'ils ont découvert la bactérie il
y a un an ils n'ont pas l'obligation
d'avertir merci et c'est ça qui est
assez effarant c'est que c'est sur la
base du volontariat et que donc bah ok
il découvre une bactérie donc ils
peuvent prendre les mesures en interne
mais il y a aucun aucune information qui
remonte au niveau de l'État et pour une
boîte comme vittoni ou Nestlé à mon sens
cette extrêmement grave de se dire que
ils peuvent découvrir ce qu'ils veulent
mais que c'est sur la base de
volontariat de le faire remonter au
niveau de l'État oui je pense surtout
que bettonie c'est très bien qu'il y a
absolument pas de risque financiers pour
eux puisque en France l'amende qui vont
avoir et demander 255 millions je crois
ils n'auront jamais ça ça serait du
jamais vu jamais vu il y a les gens vont
avoir oui ils vont avoir au maximum
30000 euros par personne il y a 55 ça
fait 1 million 7 et pour buter c'est que
dalle Z que dalle alors Béatrice la
seule façon de sauver la marque à mon
avis ce serait justement de proposer des
contrôles réguliers avec une
responsabilité incontrôler indépendant
avec une responsabilité c'est un traçage
de qui a contrôlé et que quelqu'un a une
personne physique et prenne une
responsabilité et à ce moment là je
pense que les gens reprendront confiance
dans dans ces aliments